uh what could you get for it you think I
would not be interested in having any
conversations for you know less than uh
you know on the order of like what you
got like the hustle or um uh morning
Brew or you know stuff like that tens of
millions yeah yeah yeah uh I mean I just
think like the value of what we've built
both as a business and revenue and our
audience uh and our durability is you
know is is in that category
[Music]
laughs
all right what's up we got a uh
crossover episode call me Tim Hardaway
we got the guys from acquired yeah you
like that you like that that's good
that's good baby yeah that's for the uh
the five percent of of listeners who who
know about basketball so we got uh the
guys from acquired are here we're doing
kind of um a joint episode a uh the old
Alabama wedding as I like to call it you
know just we're just getting we're
getting cousins together here because
you guys got a podcast that is uh pretty
awesome I remember when I was working at
uh at our previous startup a guy came to
me was like there's a podcast You're
Gonna Love it's called Acquired and I go
what is it he goes it's like the
backstories of these like of all Great
Tech Acquisitions like how it all went
down they go into like all the nerdy
details and then I binged you guys for
like six days straight
um and so that was that's how I kind of
first got into it a couple years ago so
welcome to the show David and Ben thank
you we did a super fun Crossover with
you a couple years ago now all but it
was just with Sean Sam you were off
traveling the world doing amazing things
uh well that's what he said he was like
you're probably doing something amazing
I was like uh probably just like a
doctor's appointment or something
it's probably yeah you guys have totally
come up since then the uh I mean you
were big back then but uh that was like
within the first couple months I think
of you starting this and uh it's just
been awesome to watch how far you've
come that was kind of an art even though
it was year four or five for us that was
kind of our early days too because uh
Sean you're right that we were mostly
about Acquisitions at that point and we
talked about the bibo acquisition right
as part of the episode and now we do
these like three four hour entire you
know history and strategy of a company
regardless of whether there was a
transaction but
um yeah that that feels like uh I don't
know the funny thing about exponential
growth is it feels like a lifetime ago
all the time I always think about that
like when you pick a niche and then you
kind of are gonna run out but the niche
can get you somewhere so for example I
was thinking about this with coffee
Zilla the YouTube guy who exposed
business people's scams and I'm like and
then he did one the other day that was
like
he dm'd a celebrity to promote some nft
thing like hey we'll pay you to promote
this nft thing and like the white paper
said like this shit's a scam or whatever
but he didn't read it obviously he just
promoted it he's like huh scammer and
I'm like but you cut that's kind of
entrapment like you you're running out
of people to like to to cover here you
ended up create scammers like I don't
think that's like Ali G back in the day
yeah exactly but like that wasn't his
original stick but I was like yeah
you're not gonna like you're trying to
be on this YouTube once a week treadmill
and there's not once a week gonna be a
giant Logan Paul like celebrity name did
this bad thing and I'm gonna be the
exposer it's like what are you gonna do
next Tuesday because there's not like
this isn't that that current uh but you
guys did a good job of switching it up
people said that to us Sean they go
you're gonna run out ideas and I was
like yeah we might but then it just kind
of like morphed into like us saying a
lot of like it's like people are when I
someone yesterday was like what's your
podcast about I was like well the name's
pretty bad it's definitely a lot about
business but we also make a lot of
horrible more jokes too so people kind
of like it for that reason
yeah I've been thinking about this a lot
your Niche earns you the right to exist
but it's in in media but it's your um
your sort of demeanor and your the way
that you look at the world that then
gives you license to expand from there
so like if David labor my friend
I just think if David and I had started
with like we're a podcast that talks
about businesses it's like cool next but
if you like pitch people on really
specifically what they're what you'd
like the job to be done of your show and
their life is then you can sort of like
expand and explore from there right like
benj Ben should have been producer Ben
should have been like you know you know
Mormons taking over the world started
with the Mormon Community then expanded
from there I remember talking to the
guys from wait but why that great blog
yeah and
um this guy wait guys is there a team
it's not just him it's Tim and then it's
his childhood friend Andrew who does
like the back end all the business stuff
they have a really interesting business
they like acquire companies that are
completely unrelated to white but why
like that's how they make their money
and then they just want fun like that's
kind of the the model but I was asking
him about content
because I was like you know I admire way
but why so tell me about this and I was
like you know I'm trying to figure this
out I kind of like to talk about this
and I kind of like to talk about this
and he's like you need your uh like your
Flagship franchise and you do your
franchise and then people will love that
franchise but they'll also love you and
they'll you'll earn the right to talk to
them about like oh you want to talk
about like mindset stuff cool but unless
you think mindset is the right place to
start wait earn the the Trust on the
business side and then say by the way
here's my mindset stuff and then you'll
get some percentage of people have
crossed over and then a new audience
there too you just keep launching new
franchises after that I love it it's so
cheap it's also like the we even you
guys you know you started several years
after us but like I think you still work
when did you guys start
three years ago
September of 2019 I think or July yeah
later than yeah we were 2015. but even
in 29 like it was still kind of earliest
enough days in podcasting that like the
medium was the mainstream portion of
podcasting meeting was still early
enough that people were looking for new
stuff right and like that I think has
changed now in a pretty big way the way
that it started was basically like I was
in Austin or somewhere I was living in
San Francisco at the time and Sean
texted me and he was like hey I have an
idea for a podcast here's the pilot do
you guys wanna does hustle want to be
the publisher and I listened to it and I
like I just listened to the intro and I
was like yep we're in let's just air
this exact one next week and we'll start
by the way that was a little bit of a
fib I I basically told you I was like
hey you know why I was like why don't
you do podcasts and Sam was like ah like
I gotta hire somebody to do it I don't
know we were focused on this email thing
I was like well
I got a podcast I'm gonna do a podcast
will you be the publisher he's like and
I was like I already I knew that to seal
the deal I needed to send him a file but
I hadn't recorded yet so I go I already
did the first episode uh you want like
take a listen to it and then I like just
ghosted him on messenger for 24 hours so
I could go record the episode then came
back was like oh my bad here's the file
so there really wasn't an episode when I
first messaged you but I was like I got
the vibe that if this is good if I get
like a good first 35 seconds this is
done and uh so that's what I went and
did yeah and we were like we're in and
then he did it his way it was called my
first million because it was like first
million users Revenue whatever and it
was great it was great as it was but
like there was one time like three
months in where a guest didn't show up
and he was like uh I booked the space do
you just want to come and like talk and
I was like I guess and we did that and
then it kind of like did well but like
our the first episode he did by himself
it got 65 000 downloads and we were like
dude podcasting podcasting is easy this
is gonna be awesome and then over the
next 12 months it basically went down to
like as low as maybe 10 or 15 000 and
then since then it's basically just been
a slow grind now we're anywhere from 100
to 200 000 per dot per episode if you
include the YouTube our YouTube is is
pretty weak it's like 20 to 50 000 20 to
100 000 and then the RSS feed which is
like iTunes and all that stuff that's um
maybe a hundred uh or something like
that what uh where are you guys at
because like no one talks about this
stuff like whenever you Google I
remember we were Googling like how do we
get to 100 000 downloads but everyone
out there was like here's how you get
your first thousand first ten thousand I
was like okay but like how do we get
bigger we're we're almost the exact same
scale with a very different journey I
mean every journey is unique on this
stuff uh so our episodes get about 200
000 downloads listens whatever you want
to call it
um uh which is interesting because
Spotify has become so much more of the
market now uh per episode but unlike you
guys we do like one episode a month you
know one to two episodes a month and
they're really really long
so uh we I have with a few exceptions
that we can talk about we've never had
like kind of big spike viral you know
breakout moments it's been a you know
eight year Journey from like zero up to
that
um we don't really have spikes like
there's spiky stuff but it's not like a
true like virality moment and
interesting you guys so one thing that's
interesting about content media is
everybody measures the number nobody
measures the quality because the quality
is way harder to understand yeah but
clearly there's a difference between 200
000 people listening to an episode of
acquired versus 200 000 views on a tick
tock okay we get that because it's kind
of short versus long but even if it was
a podcast about sports versus a podcast
about business Acquisitions the type of
people that are going to listen to your
thing are just inherently more valuable
um have you guys thought about that seen
that do you guys uh I mean that's the
whole that is the whole business not
that you started or do this for the
business side although it's become a
great business this um that is the whole
business side and and also on the
content side too like we made we started
doing this for us to learn and then we
were like well who you know would also
want to learn for video people like us
and that's kind of who we make it for
like
um so we struggle with YouTube with Tick
Tock with Twitter like we're not good on
any of those other platforms even though
we do atomize content and do it now
because like we don't it's just not kind
of how we designed the show and to to
ground it uh 40 of acquired listeners
are c-level or VP level Executives 23
are currently Founders 12 were
previously Founders and if you break
down by job Seventeen percent or
engineers 15 are actively CEOs today and
12 are product managers and so like the
whole business for us and to David's
point it didn't start as a business but
where we are today is like
I don't really want millions of
listeners I want acquired to like kind
of slow its growth but saturate the
niche that we're in because I think it's
the most valuable audience in the world
right and I don't know exactly what that
leads to but like all the conversations
David and I get to have with our
listeners because of who they are are
like super fascinating
well what will it lead to so like you
know you do you you can probably make a
great living off of just the advertising
but I'm looking at your site you don't
sell anything
um What's It Gonna lead to well we do
have merch uh who do you're wearing
right now is pretty dope
this is marquez's Hoodie yeah uh which
uh uh David ml who's on marquez's team
is a uh uh become a good friend and is
an acquired listener and uh he hooked me
up with this this hoodie rocks yeah I I
sent the picture to our merch person I
screenshotted uh and I had that moment
where I was like you know that thing we
were on a zoom call I don't know if you
guys do this but you screenshot and it's
like makes the really loud ass sound of
like a screenshot has been taken and
then you gotta like address it like it
was a fart during the during the call I
was really worried that when I said I
can't help if we were doing that thing
uh on every slide of my deck this is a
total digression and we'll come back to
it but um fourth wall uh makes there so
Marquez is an investor in fourth wall
Walker Williams the founder he was the
founder of Teespring uh awesome guy
we've gotten to know him um we're
talking to them now I think yeah yeah
merch yeah they're uh they are great and
they made this fully custom for Marquez
uh and it's it's the best Marquez being
uh what's his name Brownlee is that his
MKBHD yeah the uh the you I mean you
said first name like he's Oprah like you
know I was like
oh it's that guy well he has like 20
million YouTube subscribers I mean I
just know him as like the guy who
interview uh reviews uh uh Tech but he
also like has interviewed Tesla uh Elon
and all these like great guys I mean
he's cool unless they've come on this
podcast they're I don't know them this
podcast in my mind
he's also the craziest thing is like as
if it wasn't enough to operate this like
pretty large scale TV Production Studio
at this point as a as a YouTuber
um he's also like one of the best
Ultimate Frisbee players in the world oh
really yeah he's a professional Ultimate
Frisbee player I didn't see that I can
see it that's a very obvious crossover
do you so like when we'll just talk real
Insider baseball for a second and then
we'll move on but with podcasting a lot
of people ask us how to start it and
stuff like that and I'm like I don't
know how to grow it it's quite
challenging but what I've really enjoyed
getting to know is like Andrew huberman
I'm you know I'm acquaintances but not
friends friends with him really but like
we'll chat every once in a while and
he's like I've seen each other with
their shirts off but we I mean I
wouldn't call each other friends but
like
we've sauna together this is like oh I
was probably at a doctor's appointment
but like your life is just like I listen
to you guys I'm like wow no bro he was
he was on our but he was on our pod so
like I know him like an hour plus like
five text messages exchanged so like
that's the extent that I know him uh but
he I think there if you look at Spotify
when he releases an episode it's
typically the most popular on uh the
charts and I think they're in the
million Mark million per uh episode
which is how we like to measure it is
there anyone else in the business
category that's in the 205 I mean all in
is probably 400 maybe 500 000 do you
know like how big do you have to be to
be some of the biggest of course there's
Dave Ramsey he's he's in a whole
different category yeah it's funny it
depends because like business kind of
gets lumped in with all these other like
personal finance type categories but I
think in our ilk
um yeah they should make it separate the
best budgeting category and move Dave
Ramsey's ass over there yeah yeah
uh you know and it's all into like has
been an amazing breakout they've become
more of a mainstream news and political
show I mean they still talk Tech in
business but um that I think is a lot of
Their audience and they're huge now but
yeah our category I would say like
invest like the best probably is the
most directly comparable in terms of
size and audience makeup also Founders
and David Sandra
um and he's part of the Colossus network
with Patrick
um who else uh
Jason's other show this week in startups
uh that we go on all the time but Logan
Bartlett has
um a much smaller audience because he's
much newer but like a plus guests and
really I mean he's I think he's he's got
the the most valuable niche of niche in
terms of the people who listen to his
show why because of VCS
it's like
Silicon Valley insiders for lack of a
better I mean it's VCS it's Founders but
I think like his interviews I always
feel like he pulls out the most valuable
geez
small boy stuff right there let me ask
you a different question that I've
actually never asked so so you so David
said something a second ago which is
kind of like
the paraphrase would be we made the
podcast for people like us or we made
the podcast that we would want to listen
to is that fair to kind of summarize
your position David 100 and I feel like
that with this podcast I started the
milk road that way but it quickly
transformed into like crypto news which
is actually not what I actually a lot of
people know this I've said this I don't
read or consume the news so it's really
funny that we made a news like thing and
got it big and then sold it but like
truthfully it didn't end up becoming the
thing that like I made this for me for
people like me out there Sam do you
subscribe to that like I guess like in
theory you could say the best thing to
do is to scratch your own itch to build
the product you want be you know make it
for people like you then you're not
guessing but then in practice sometimes
you know the mass Market is not where
you're at and you go for that so Sam
what's your take on that I think we it
was it started MFM started that way and
it is mostly that way every once in a
while you know Sean will be like we need
more views let's like get this guessed
and sometimes we give into it sometimes
we don't the hustle started out because
I liked the news and then about a year
two years in I was like I don't care
about the news anymore but this is my
job so I'm gonna keep doing it
um I don't I don't I listen to zero
business podcasts now I basically only
listen to like crime and fiction and
things like that and so I don't listen
to business podcast anymore but I think
this podcast has mostly stayed of just
like what do I want to do what does Sean
what do we want to talk about yeah it's
mostly stayed that way but we we do like
have to fight like I was messaging Sean
like this uh this last night and I was
like dude we need to be stricter about
our guests because we've had like a
bunch of people uh like who asked to
come on and we're like yeah they're huge
and then I'm like wait I don't give a
about this person I don't like I
don't I wouldn't want to have like if
this person invited me over for dinner I
wouldn't be excited and so we definitely
have to fight that I would assume you
know this is we're realizing that it's
the case for us although it's different
because we tell stories but um for you
guys I would like the reason your
audience is here so for you right like
it's not for your gas right yeah I think
sometimes though the the guests you know
I basically told Sam I said there's
three to three three or four types to
guess for the here's the four that I
think exists there's the people that are
like us and they're just bringing a
different like Flavor new fresh ideas so
like for example when you guys first
came on you guys you got the stick you
knew what we do on this podcast I
remember you guys came with a bunch of
business ideas you're like oh this
Airbnb Wi-Fi network that's like you
know oh my God you remember even the
idea yes I saw your face that I did came
back to me right I got like that some
people have photographic memory I have
an idea memory I can remember any idea
so that was like you guys got the stick
so you came on you brought ideas which
is great because the audience loves that
Steph Smith is a great example of this
she comes on she brings ideas people
like her even though she's not the big
name you know famous oh CEO of X she
does an amazing job so that's like
number one number two is basically like
they are the big name so somebody who a
bunch of people are gonna click on it
might bring new audience it's like
you're you're legit famous in some way
you had a pop on recently yeah well how
he would be three which is internet
famous it's like legit famous it's like
you know they're they've they kind of
like outside my Paris Hilton or
something yeah like they don't have a
podcast or they don't have a newsletter
they don't have like an internet
Community they're just like famous
famous then there's you're internet
famous and the last one is personal like
we want to nerd out with them and so
that would be like like Ariel helwani
yeah we had arrow hawani on like I don't
know how much of our audience cared
about that but I cared I wanted to have
that conversation
um and we've had you know Sam was like
oh this guy Ken write out is awesome
he's like this 50 year old like Marathon
record breaker guy like I just want to
talk to him and it's like great let's do
that so it's kind of like we are going
to be so into the conversation and we
are sure that this person is interesting
to us it'll be interesting to some
portion of the audience and so it's like
to us those are the four and I think the
one you get tripped up on the most is
just the the legit famous person because
they they don't actually listen to the
Pod they may not bring bring the juice
and it's almost like the expectations
are high and you almost disappoint
because it's like oh
all right well that was kind of a lame
conversation with that person
and they don't have any of their own
distribution the nice thing about
internet famous is at least they can
help distribute the content but real
regular famous people it's like unless
they're getting put in People magazine
or cast in the latest movie they
actually have no way to reach an
audience directly yeah you know who does
that for us is darmesh the founder of
HubSpot every time he comes on he get
his episodes get really popular and he's
always doing he is popular and his
content is great and also he always does
some internet marketing stuff where he
he kills it he kills him for us every
time that's that's the best kind of
guest that'll come on and promote right
and he pays the bills too so he's the
sponsor he's the guest he drives the
girl yeah come on acquired the crazy
thing we notice about guests recently
just looking at our analytics and the
the two things and both of them are true
100 of the time without fail one
every single time we set a new episode
record it is an episode that is like
just David and I doing Nintendo lvmh
Berkshire Hathaway like our canonical
three-hour format and two every single
time we have a guest on it is
less listened to than our previous
episode yeah interesting
just last question is how do you guys
prepare for that do you just like both
read the same book and take notes and
then just tell a story we mostly read
different stuff but uh we've kind of
architected I mean this is our like our
differentiation as a show which is so
anti-all the rules of podcasting but I
think is what makes us special is we
have carved out that like we can take a
month in our lives and do you know it's
kind of like if you're writing a term
paper in college like we can do the
research independently each of us on a
company on a topic and then we come
together and it's like uh I don't know
it's like a thesis defense or something
that we do the goal is like between the
two of us to have basically consumed
every piece of content on the company
like every other podcast that's ever
been done all the big books that have
been written all the talks given by the
founder try and find a bunch of weird
stuff like talks given at industry
conferences that have low view counts on
YouTube obviously read all the sources
of all of the Wikipedia page for the
companies it's basically like no one
should be able to DM us after the
episode and be like oh did you did you
see this important piece of information
on the company we want to always be like
defensively no we have consumed
everything about this company and I
think like I think the magic is that
like if we if the output of that were a
term paper it would be really boring and
nobody would read it but because the
output of that is Ben and I as really
good friends like talking about it like
that kind of makes it magical yeah the
friends we've been noodling on is
conversational audiobooks oh that's cool
to describe what it is are there any odd
commonalities that you've seen amongst
like the Savages that you've done
stories on so for example Ben Wilson has
you know he does uh how to take over the
world and it's historical figures and
he's like you know it's weird John
Rockefeller Edison and Napoleon a bunch
of these other people they ate really
lightly like they didn't eat a ton of
food because they said that when they
over ate they felt brain fog and but for
a bunch of different reasons are there
any uh strange commonalities that you've
you've found amongst like these
conquerors of the world
well we talk more about companies than
we do about people like Ben and David
Center over at Founders or companies
yeah or companies
I mean it's the classic like being
contrarian and right and you have to be
both contrarian and right but the people
that were studying and the companies
that we're studying are such extreme
outliers like they're such the they're
four standard deviations from the mean
in terms of like how did a company do
and so
they were they're sort of like an N of
one like there's one tsmc in the world
there's one lvmh who owns all the most
valuable luxury Brands except Hermes uh
and it sort of happens in a unique way
every time and so I guess the the
biggest takeaway for me is like it
usually is the founder doing something
that like literally everybody else had
left for dead and and when I say that I
mean like Bernard or no going and buying
Christian Dior from the French
government out of bankruptcy in when was
that the 80s David 80s yeah or like
literally no one else was bidding on
this like dead asset or uh the the
example for starting tsmc is like zero
other people thought that you should be
starting a Foundry when you have no chip
IP to make other people's chip designs
like that was there were zero other
people like there is no there is no
formula every story is unique but a big
big category is like something that has
been left for dead for like sometimes
it's inventing something new whole cloth
but like really big category is like oh
this thing is over and over David
Nintendo yeah Nintendo Google video game
Crash of 1983 like the market for video
games in the United States went from
three billion dollars to a hundred
million dollars over the course of two
years everybody was running screaming
from the industry and they thought oh
video games were a fad and it's over and
then you have Nintendo that comes in
launches the NES and then within five
years has 95 market share and has grown
the industry back to a three billion
dollar industry it's these like Nut Job
bets has that has that like given you
guys any confidence to succeed do you
think like because John and I talked to
all these awesome people and like we'll
talk to there are a handful of people
and I said this a bunch there's a
handful of people who we talk to and we
say oh you're definitely like
significantly smarter than we are or
you're you're significant you have this
part that's more significant than us and
then there's other people who we'll talk
to that are worth hundreds of millions
or billions of dollars and it's like
well you're not like 20 times smarter
than us even though you're 20 times
richer but like you might be a little
bit or sometimes a little bit less and
that's given us confidence at least me
for sure because I'm like oh you
definitely are insecure you uh question
yourself you doubt yourself but you
still went through with it it's a good
question like I know how to be
contrarian I'm not sure I know how to be
right yet like
we're halfway there baby yeah yeah
exactly like I I I you know we know how
to make everyone tells you you should
make short podcasts that release every
single week and you should have guests
on to help build your audio and we do
basically none of those things and
everything that has worked for us is
doing the exact opposite of those and so
does that mean keep doing the opposite
of every piece of advice everyone gives
you because that's the path to success I
don't think so but if we overfit to the
data that we've observed so far that is
what it would look like and so I'm
hesitant to like keep being contrarian
for the sense of being contrarian but
but I think that the important part that
comes with this is like having a
iterative feedback loop with your
customers or in our case with our
listeners to understand like what makes
you love this and how do we lean harder
into that and and sort of shut out
general advice and pay more attention to
like the the things our customers are
expressing by the way I've picked up a
little poker tell on
people who are uncontract how do you
tell a real contrarian versus a wannabe
contrarian this is a hotel I picked up
over time which is yeah yeah uh in the
tech world I think because of Peter
Thiel there's this like kind of like
real sex appeal to fetishization
contrary and uh if you put in your
Twitter bio you're probably not it yeah
exactly same with polymath yeah
polymath's another one of them
um as being or Visionary as being as me
and Sam have joked about like or like if
you're an engineer being like slightly
on the Spectrum it's like oh yeah yeah
that's another indicator of success it's
like here we go the one that is I think
a tell when it comes to being contrarian
is how excited are you that you have
this contrarian idea because that shows
people who are contrarian for the sake
of being contrarian meaning like they're
really excited to tell you how they
think everybody else thinks a but it's
actually B
um whereas the real people I've seen
that are contrarian they just see a and
they're almost like I'm confused why
people don't think a a is clearly right
um
uh they don't spend time trying to like
convince the whole world of it like you
know if if they're asked they tell the
truth and then when people react in a
big way like oh man I can't believe you
think that and they're like I can't
believe you don't think that
um it just seems like the truth to them
and so that's what I've noticed is like
if you if you watch old videos of like
you know Peter teal talking or like I
think biology is somebody who's like
this today
um they SP they they're happy to explain
their point of view and they explain it
like this is just what's gonna happen or
this is what I believe to be true but
they don't
um get high on the idea of of being a
contrarian it's a subtle difference
there's a bunch of people I've met in
real life that that I kind of I've
noticed this on it's hard to explain but
you'll see next time you kind of run
into somebody who's over eager and over
excited about the fact that they have
this contrarian opinion it's they're
kind of just performing socially versus
they actually believe that it reminds me
a lot of um it's like we all know this
guy or girl who likes the idea of a
relationship more than they like their
current relationship and they're they're
very excited to like have this
particular lifestyle and you can sort of
tell you're into that new lifestyle you
have more than the person you're
actually with right so right did you
want a boyfriend or did you want Ben
right like who did you actually want to
hear
um yeah let me tell a story it's
interesting though like okay I was just
gonna tell one on the thing Sam you
talked about like what are the
interesting success patterns
um it reminded me of an experience I had
uh a while back I went to China when I
was maybe 21 years old and got to go to
the Alibaba like Alibaba flew out a
bunch of entrepreneurs to go like meet
with it was supposed to be Jack ma but
we ended up meeting with this guy David
way who's like their Jack Ma's right
hand man he was the guy who was running
Alibaba at the time and I didn't even
know what Alibaba was like Alibaba was a
big deal like now and now I'm like now I
would have taken that really seriously I
I had no idea who they were at the time
and we get there and somebody asked him
this question they raise their hand they
go what do you think is the most
important things for Success uh for the
success of a company Alibaba is a
multi-billion dollar company
um you know what what made it successful
and he goes
um
he goes models for Success are
misleading they cannot be copied due to
the like unique combination of luck
timing all these other things but he
goes but what you can ask me is a better
question which is what are the common
keys to failure and he goes they're
always the same and he goes we study the
things that lead to failure and just try
to avoid those so he goes uh you know I
leaned in I was like please blow my mind
sir go ahead yeah and he's like um he
goes there's three things that lead to
failure money plans a technology he goes
so our plan was no money no plans no
technology and I go what and like this
is crazy because like a tech company
worth like 40 billion dollars like what
are you talking about and he goes hey he
goes all right here we go money money
makes people stupid and when problems
come up their first instinct becomes
throw money at it rather than attacking
it with creativity so basically way back
when Google was uh Google was like
dominating with AdWords and so they're
the people at Alibaba were like we need
to make our version of AdWords and he
goes you know this is no it's like you
know building this type of AD network is
not like super simple
um he goes so Jack ma cut a check for
250 000 to build this project and latim
like laughed like you're you're missing
three zeros on the back of this like
what are you talking about 250k and he
goes That's how much money it took me to
start Alibaba
um like I I had less than that starting
the whole company so if you need more
than that for a feature we're doing it
wrong he's like they're like well how
are we supposed to do this he goes do
exactly what I did with Alibaba he's
like so he moved 19 people into his
apartment where he had started out he's
like that's your office you're gonna
work there he's like you need uh servers
to run the ad servers cool go find some
like uh go get some used junk servers
and like re-rig them get them refurbish
them and make them work and they go but
there's no redundancy he goes if you're
building within where you need
redundancy like we've we've done this
wrong right like uh you know this is you
need to build build this so that it
works without redundancy first and um
and so he he did that for that was the
no money then he's like no technology
he's like everybody wants to call us at
tech company no we are a Service Company
we're here to serve our users if you
don't think of yourself like you're in
the service industry you're in the wrong
industry and uh this last one was
planned and it's like all right well
dude how'd you do this like why no plans
why are plans bad he goes
um
he goes well you know you guys are 50
young entrepreneurs who got flown out
here to do this I I assume in America
you guys have done something good
otherwise why would we have picked you
he goes how many of you are doing what
you initially plan to do
and like nobody's hand went up and he
was like exactly and he goes uh plan is
plans are fine but they always change
that's the only thing we know about
plans the mission never wavers sometimes
you'll need a plan to get others to
believe but remember you should not
believe that plan you should follow your
gut and adapt constantly to the
circumstances don't follow the plan you
wrote when you started follow your
mission follow your vision follow the
why if you do that you will be
successful and I was like damn dude did
you write all this down
so so many years ago after that after
that event I wrote I tried to write a
book in like two weeks and I wrote half
of it and so this was one of my chapters
in that book uh and I just found the PDF
on my computer when you were talking
about awesome that's hilarious that's
amazing that you did that because that
was years ago what a great story it's so
applicable I love that that's applicable
to Alibaba uh just as much as like I'm
thinking about you guys and us and like
how we started the conversation like
yeah we had no money we had I guess we
had technology in that like podcasting
and the internet is inherently one of us
were like we're building a tech company
or we're building a product it was like
no it's like
something and we have no plan
and like it's funny like I we see a lot
I'm sure you guys do too people come to
us like oh how do I start a podcast I
start a successful podcast we see like
big companies come the like offline
celebrities that want to start podcasts
and it's like they come with money
technology and a play out and they're
like it's not how it's gonna work that
it's gonna suck you guys probably see
this with your episodes like how many of
them started doing what they're doing
like I don't know I haven't listened to
all the recent ones but like I don't
know was Nintendo what were you thinking
of Nintendo today or did it dude
Nintendo was making wait wait real quick
do either of you know the origin story
of Nintendo or or have a guess at how
old Nintendo is I think it's really I
remember reading it once I don't I don't
remember off top of my head but it was
is it like Sony where they were like
selling rice or something and then now
they're who they are it's even better
yeah it's a 130 year old company
89 I think yeah and their original
business was making hanafuda cards which
is the Japanese version of us playing
cards but U.S playing cards were illegal
to import like because people from the
US could were it was not legal to be in
the country and David I think you at
this point they literally would execute
you yeah you came in well Nintendo
started straight after this but before
the metis restoration like Japan went
through this multi-hundred year period
of strict isolationism where like you
would be executed if you were a
foreigner and you entered the country
likewise if you were a Japanese person
and you left the country and came back
you would also be executed like
um and but like playing cards are this
thing that like has product Market fits
they're like how do we gamble things
like playing cards Universal human need
so it literally started making hanafuda
cards and their distribution channel was
through the Yakuza to Illegal casinos
yeah Yakuza being like the Mafia the
Japanese Mafia yeah yeah they started
making these playing cards and like if
very small part of the market was like
oh you have a pack of playing cards in
your house but just like everywhere else
in the world the market is casinos
because you use a fresh deck for each
hand so that there's no cheating and
yeah so Nintendo is like deeply embedded
with the Yakuza and for like 60 years
this was their business before they
started making toys wow and then what
some like Visionary within the company
was like uh hey there's this new thing
crazy family like really tragedy of like
this cycle of
um death and uh just like terrible
parenting in the past down to four
generations of the same family but
actually not the same family because
they had no sons and they needed Sun so
they were marrying their daughters off
to people who could take over the
business yeah exactly and uh one of
these guys was basically just like so
pissed off at like the family Legacy
that uh this is Hiroshi Yamauchi who
started the modern Nintendo uh and he
was like and he wanted to First buy the
business I want to get out of this and
he did a partnership with Disney in 1959
yeah 1959 he Nintendo brought Disney and
Disney IP into Japan post World War II
check this out I literally have the
cards as toys acquired fans sent them to
me oh wow started words
yeah and then they brought toys and then
they started making their own toys
because they had like lock on the retail
Distributors uh yeah wow so it started
his cards and they were like then they
went said all these uh retailers they
were like oh you want the Disney
products you're gonna take our products
too was that Jiminy Cricket as the Joker
Jiminy Cricket as the Joker in Mickey
Mouse golfing on this old school card
deck that's amazing that's like you
gotta wear that with you gotta wear
gloves if you're gonna touch that or
something that's like a seriously
ancient artifact
this data is wrong every freaking time
have you heard of HubSpot
HubSpot is a CRM platform where
everything is fully integrated well I
can see the client's whole history calls
support tickets emails and here's a test
from three days ago I totally missed
HubSpot grow better
can I ask you guys a couple rapid fire
questions uh about some of the companies
that you've you've discussed number one
which company of all of everyone that
you've uh won over would you want to own
like which one what's the one that you
envy well that way those are two
different questions which would you want
to okay like own the stock of and which
do you want or which do you want to like
uh be an investor in or actually own the
company yeah yeah the second actually
own and which one do you envy most
actually own I think is the NFL
yeah I think that has the most like
durable franchise and own is always a
funny question because what's your entry
price like do I have to buy stuff at
today's prices or but if I think about
sort of like durability of the asset and
I sort of ignore
um where things are trading and what
Market values today
the NFL is seven layers of entrenched in
our society and to be an American at
this point means to have the NFL in your
life and they also David you pointed
this out on our episode everyone thinks
it's really cute to like stack rank all
the media franchises Marvel's worth this
and you know all the way at the top of
the charts Pokemon's worth this but like
the NFL is worth so much more than any
of those the NFL TV contract alone is 12
billion dollars a year the most recent
set of Rights they parsled up was like
no isn't it uh now it's like 18 or 19
billion a year I think something insane
but then they recently signed a 10-year
deal so it's like a 150 billion dollar
deal
NFL has all the franchises but is there
basically like this like top level hold
Co that owns like the media rights and
the franchise it's communist capitalism
they all own it all together but the NFL
unlike any of the other leagues out
there is this is there's starting to be
a few little cracks in this but like
they didn't negotiate with the TV
contracts and now all the streaming and
everything unified as a league so
there's no like you know like how the
Yankees have the Yes Network like their
own TV Network it's none of that in the
NFL it's all together and it's all equal
Revenue share have you guys done an
episode on MLB am yes
it's actually the first investment
before the acquisition these guys can
tell you the the full version they're
accurate version I'll give you the dumb
version which is the Major League
Baseball had created a tech like a tech
team basically a tech company inside of
Major League Baseball co-owned by like
the the teams and the good job was like
Hey like people are trying to listen to
this on the radio we need to like do
Digital streaming audio Ichiro because
when Ichiro came over from Japan they
needed to stream remember that guy Sam
Ichiro Suzuki the guy who played on the
Mariners yeah yeah it was like a
phenomenon and so people in Japan wanted
to watch or watch wasn't even an option
I think it was listen to the games so
they needed Digi internet streaming
audio and so they built this thing they
started offering here then each team
would use it so it's like oh each team
co-funded it so they would like cut a
check and then that developed technology
for all of them but then they ended up
spinning it out as a multi-billion
dollar company because they're the best
at video streaming now like they stream
if you want to watch Game of Thrones
it's MLB am's video tech that streams
Game of Thrones so that when whatever 10
million people click play as soon as the
episode drops that like the thing
doesn't crash which is kind of a you
know just an amazing thing and so that
like spin out oh like who would have
ever thought like one of the big tech
companies you know unicorn tech
companies came out of like this baseball
Co-op co-funded thing is that kind of an
insane story
and it was in like 2004 or something
that they started working on it they had
a five-year head start on having the
Insight that this infrastructure was
going to be important over Netflix like
everyone thinks like oh Netflix you know
is in with the isps and it's the best in
the world that this like damn Tech was
doing that five years earlier
yeah and it ended up getting acquired by
Disney and like is a huge part of ESPN
streaming like all the um ESPN plus plus
Disney plus like it's it's crazy the
history is there is there a certain
founder CEO leader who you would rank as
the the person you'd least want to
compete against whether they're whether
historical or modern here's another
phrasing that I heard that I like
there's somebody who's talking about the
NFL draft and there's like four QBs that
were competing and they're like wow this
guy's got good arm this guy's good at
running this guy's a great leader blah
blah and then this guy asked this
question I loved he goes let's say they
all went on vacation and they rented a
car and they're walking out to the to
the Jeep
who do they throw the keys to to drive
this car it's like who's the leader
who's the alpha amongst Alphas amongst
these QB so so who's that in the CEO I
think we gotta say Jensen uh Jensen long
from Nvidia like he's such a badass so
like I don't know anything about Nvidia
because I just know it's a killer stock
so Nvidia makes the chips that are in
computers and and does it involves
display like you can get like a Nvidia
yeah is that right yeah
is uh is in their sort of third major
act as a company yeah but Loosely
defined as like they
um popularized the idea of a GPU in
addition to the CPU and originally the
use case was for video games in the 90s
and you know I think everyone who ever
built PCS remembers like oh man I gotta
get this hot new GPU to slide in the
card because it's better than the
integrated Graphics thing from Intel
um and so that was sort of their market
for a while and uh it was all about
gaming PCs but then like again five six
seven years before the rest of the
Market Jensen basically made this bet
where he saw researchers using the the
gpus the gaming Graphics they're really
going to Best Buy and buying a bunch of
Nvidia graphics cards to do AI research
and he was like I think we should lean
really heavily into this and so he spent
billions of dollars and thousands of
head count for five years to build up
this like whole software stack called
cuda that if Ai and ml was going to
become a thing then people were going to
use Cuda to develop exclusively on
nvidia's hardware and so by the time it
did become a thing like five years ago
Nvidia had this enormous moat around it
as being the platform to develop AI on
and it just so happened that the
technology this like super heavy
parallel processing Matrix math
technology that makes gaming Graphics
chips work is the very same math that
powers what ml is all based on but other
than so Nvidia for The Listener it's I
just looked it up it says 650 billion
dollar company so one of the I don't
know top 20 30 biggest business in the
world but other than him being correct
what makes this person like a savage or
that they're just like there's so many
points in history like he is uh 19 wives
let me no he actually he's a total
family man he's been married to the same
person he met in college if two kids
like he's uh but like he's got a giant
tattoo of the company's logo on his
shoulder uh he wears leather jackets he
drives really fast cars he's like um
like Elon except not like like right
like
right and like leads with kindness and
uh but like he I mean they're like in
each phase of the company the absolute
rational thing to do was like basically
shut it down and like you know like talk
about being left for dead like this
company was left for dead multiple times
and he's built like just single-handedly
this dude created the AI Revolution that
we are in today like Nvidia and Cuda is
essentially like you can think about it
as like the Android plus iOS of AI like
no Nvidia and no Cuda no decision by
Jensen to do this we are not living in
the world we're living in today
a different answer for the thing you're
actually looking for which is like who
is the most Savage person to compete
against that answer is Bernardo
uh and he got there not by being the
founder of a business that happened to
have product Market fit and appreciated
wildly it's because of his deal prowess
and the way that he was able to
effectively outsmart the rest of the
market to Hoover up 70 of the the
history's most important and trusted
Brands into one umbrella and then find
leverage in every single thing he does
to expand the Empire is there anyone who
you think is overrated who's on a
pedestal and you think I don't think
that person's that great I think it
worked out but I think they're overrated
it's a very unacquired question we'll
see
Dave and I are nice people we are we
don't um well pick a Deadpool one that I
like to I like to talk about it
uh damn person uh or you can pick anyone
but someone who's like no I think one
that I like to talk about here is um
I don't know the overrated is right but
like I I think a lot about it investing
about um
there's this great Buffett quote not one
of his most well-known ones but
um uh it's something like you wanna own
a business that uh you know even an
idiot could run because someday someone
will you know and I think about uh uh to
me what that means is like you want to
own a business you want to invest in a
business that like literally you cannot
kill it there's nothing you can do to
stop this Juggernaut uh and to me that's
Airbnb and we talked about this a lot on
the episode we did on airbnbly it's just
like the most amazing Global Network
effect of all time and literally like I
don't you know this is my opinion but I
don't think there's anything that any
manager could do to change the like to
inflect the trajectory of that ship you
know so my uh I uh I like there's a long
story I don't feel like telling it but I
had a job at Airbnb when I was like 22
and I like dropped out of school and
moved out and then I got denied whatever
so I didn't end up working there but I
got to interview with the founders and
then years later my wife ended up
working there and during work from home
for covid Brian would give these talks
every Thursday and we lived in a small
apartment so I like inevitably would
hear it I think that I agree with you
it's a mark once you have a Marketplace
that's working it's hard to screw it up
eBay is doing a good job though but uh
you know if it works like it's a good
it's a great thing it's a quite durable
but I would listen to Brian chesky give
these 30 minute like Thursday talks that
guy is Bad to the Bone I read a little
bit I read the Walsh uh the Walt Disney
biography and he reminded me exactly of
him he is a you know like I think
someone said there's a difference
between a missionary and a mercenary
mercenaries are Hired Guns who are
ruthless but missionaries they really
care about what they're doing
I I sense that with him that guy I think
is uh is is a bit killer I think that
he's uh people think of him as this nice
guy of which I think he is I think he's
way way more of a killer than people
give him credit for and he's very wise
that he's a really good leader
um but that's cool I like Airbnb and I
think it and I think it's cool that I
agree that it probably would be um hard
to kill and last question which person
who you covered would you would kick
your ass physically and you'd at least
want to have a physical confrontation
with I mean actually Jensen yeah you
think he you think you think so well
he's getting another age but like yeah
no he like he lifts uh
he's just like such a character uh
uh
well I certainly I mean we're coming
right off of Nintendo but like
um
Hiroshi yamuchi back in the day not
because he was physically intimidating
but like literally like that the man was
in bed with the Yakuza oh they oh you
did not cross him yeah like we sat Dave
and I walked in to interview douglioni
it's a great story and uh dougone is the
founder of Sequoia yeah
managing partner yeah got it a head
honcho at one point of one of the best
uh Venture Capital firms ever through
Google and you know the the true Heyday
of Sequoia which or you could argue that
was recently but amazing era of Sequoia
and uh so we a lot of times like with
guests we'll get to like spend some time
beforehand and get to know them and go
out to dinner afterwards and build real
relationship and we like email or text
and you guys know the drill and so with
with Doug we uh we didn't communicate
with him at all beforehand it was all
with uh some some other lovely people at
Sequoia and we walk in and we set up and
someone walks in the room and then they
go okay are you um are you ready and we
were like like yep and they were like
great we'll go get Doug walks in he sits
down he says hello
are we starting
and we're like uh yeah so we hit record
and we feel like so we did a whole
episode right
Doug just goes great thank you so much
and he walk gets up and leaves the room
so every word that I've ever spoken with
with Douglas except for like two or
three is on the record in the episode
that you can listen to on our podcast
feed and uh later his EA did come in and
say hey Doug wanted to know if you guys
had any feedback he's always looking to
get better
um and and sort of like came and Shadow
with us but I was like wow that is uh
that is not uttered by Ben or me quoting
somebody else from history uh but the
best live quote unacquired he was
talking about um after the.com crash
when uh Sequoia was like kind of made
this vow that no LP would lose money
like they wouldn't take a mulligan fund
they would like work the portfolio of
companies they don't take salaries make
sure that they have positive returns and
they said uh he's like Mike Moritz and I
linked arms or it wasn't I think it was
LinkedIn he said Mike Moritz and I
decided that like we would stand there
and we wouldn't Flinch and you could
burn cigarettes on our arms and we would
like if we wouldn't take a mulligan on
these funds like damn he also has kind
of an accent right like he's uh
he's got this Italian New York Vibe yeah
that's cool well are there are there any
more of these like tough guys or tough
women like that are out there now I mean
when I hear that it's I always think
like oh that was a different generation
nowadays
is still like this yeah
yeah
Frank uh my my badge is not working to
get into the office he's still got teeth
don't you he's like
you know that's like when you read that
guy's book you're like all right yeah
this would be a pretty hardcore boss to
work under
yeah it's totally a lost art though like
um yeah I don't I don't think they make
them like that anymore unfortunately
yeah
um that's crazy before we go do you guys
have uh have any half-baked business
ideas you wanted to share with the uh
the my first million audience because uh
that's what they love
uh yeah I would love to do this so I
have one that uh I was we were actually
kicking around uh together Ben and me
for a while
um but that we're not gonna do which is
I think uh you could actually start a
corporate podcast agency so an agency
for companies to make their own internal
podcast or external
either one uh and my thesis on this is
that for companies uh there is
tremendous value to having a podcast
even if nobody listens if people listen
like upside but even basically you
should just assume no one will listen
because we have like ever there's so
many great options why would I listen to
a company's podcast right but it is an
excuse to have relationship building
conversations with customers sales and
Biz Dev basically yeah exactly it's it's
sales enablement like once you have a
conversation you have it recorded you
publish it publicly even if there's no
organic audience you can still link to
that and you can send it to customers as
like a lead nurturing thing of oh
somebody else was in this position too
and they talked about why our product
made their life better right right yeah
like what do Salesforce should have its
own uh its own its own podcast yeah what
do they charge for that what do people
charge for that I know Ben uh Ben are
Ben Ben Wilson used to look work at UH
is it mission.org Ben or no it was
Caspian Caspian Studios and I think they
do that foreign
does this idea work or not really what
what's the verdict on this one yes it
works yes the customers are extremely
price insensitive so it's good the
margins are super high uh we actually
like combining the two things we just
talked about we made snowflakes podcast
and Frank sloopment was about it all the
time oh perfect so it's uh it's a really
good business the one bad thing about it
that's coming into effect right now is
when recessions hit it's the first thing
to go right it's just like the margins
are super good when times are good but
then when times are not the email you're
being like hey can you send me the last
30 day downloads numbers and you're like
delete yeah delete the whole podcast get
rid of it they're they're asking the
question yes
yeah
what else you got what else interests
you at the moment Ben you got any uh or
at least what deals are you seeing
because you guys are investing are there
any interesting deals that you're seeing
or categories that you're seeing that
you really like that don't start with
the word AI
I mean actually no like and and I think
that's the I think that is correct like
I am one of these people that believes
that uh
saying AI we invest in AI is a little
bit of a silly thing these days because
it's the same thing as 20 years ago
saying we invest in software as if you
see it's like yeah no like I I
think it's just gonna be so quickly
ubiquitous that like if companies aren't
using AI in some capacity or starting to
get a little bit like what's a cool AI
use case or company that you've that
you've seen and invested in or want to
invest in whatever well and by the way I
think Sean met with James Currier
recently and I think it was James on
Twitter or maybe Sean Hughes told us you
go I've been pitched by 200 AI companies
in the last quarter and I've invested in
none because they're all weak or
something like that so I haven't it's
interesting I haven't invested in any
either
or I haven't invested lots of companies
I've invested in have added AI stuff to
their products but I haven't invested in
some like net new AI company in part
because I don't think AI is going to be
the differentiation and I don't think
it's going to be defensible for the vast
majority of companies I think the the
value is going to come from and the moat
is going to come from the same thing
that always creates value and modes
which is like uh Network effects with
your customers or like a data mode where
someone's already fully locked into your
thing and so they don't want to migrate
because that would suck and they have
processes around using your thing uh and
so I sort of
like I I believe that an enormous amount
of the value from AI will accrue to
these foundational models but you
actually do have to be using the
foundational models in your thing in
order to be uh like table stakes in in
the next few years because everybody's
going to expect all software to just
behave magically
right do you think and this will be the
last question for me do you think that
there's a world where you're going to
sell acquired or do one of these Spotify
deals or anything like that
oh have you been approached good
question
uh yes but not uh not in like a um
not in not recently and not in a way
that like not since we've become a real
business uh what could you get for it
you think like Daddy I think could be
trying to give him five million bucks
but they said no
quibby oh wow
we would say no to that we would for
sure say no to that um I don't like if
uh
we could talk about like I I don't uh
uh I would not be interested in having
any conversations for you know less than
uh you know on the order of like what
you got like the hustle or um uh morning
Brew or you know stuff like that tens of
millions yeah yeah yeah uh I mean I just
think like the value of what we've built
both as a business and revenue and our
audience uh and our durability is you
know is is in that category
I think it's very much an open question
like it's gotten so much bigger than we
ever imagined
how much farther can it go uh right I'm
curious how these things would we trust
our own underwriting more than an
acquirer's underwriting because what has
happened for us is it has doubled every
single year for eight years basically no
matter what we do like we can't make it
grow faster or slower than that uh
right yeah it's it's cash generative
yeah have you guys built any businesses
off the back of it
no I'm thinking kindergarten um so I
have a fund on Angel list I manage about
30 million dollars of capital on Angelus
between two funds and four or five spvs
um and while I used to be a professional
VC before going full-time unacquired and
that certainly helps
um
all of that's because of acquired like
and you uh so so you did that you did
that fund um anything else that you guys
have done that you've launched uh off
the back of it because what we found was
that
podcast like you said it's very hard to
make it grow faster than it's kind of
like natural Word of Mouth virality in
interest and like kind of the Tam of
that that market
um like that Andrew hubermans are rare
normally It's a Grind yeah yeah and uh
and even him I don't think he can make
it grow much faster or slower just like
good execution is obviously the only
thing you control but like a lot of
people can do good execution and their
growth rate will be easier somewhat uh
uh linear you know it's not gonna like
get much fat the slope doesn't change
that much do you
um but the thing that I think what we
found was that you could build
businesses off the back of this audience
whether it's a fund or other other
products or services that
can be more valuable than the ad revenue
of the business of the podcast itself do
you guys do that or think about that
like Sean well Sean mentioned a company
and they're like oh we just did a
million in revenue and he's like oh well
I I gave a company a plug that I
invested in I was like hey I use it for
this reason blah blah you know an ad
basically but it wasn't meant to be an
ad I was just explaining how I use this
thing and they booked a million dollars
of ARR off of uh off of that which was
like pretty crazy
yeah so so that happens to us all the
time uh which is why all of our sponsor
deals are these like six-figure very
meaningful
um and long term we do these six month
sponsorships uh and most of our sponsors
are now you know three four five seasons
and like it works and so the question is
is it more is the right mode for us to
operate in keep doing these big deep
sponsorship deals with companies for
cash or do we try to start companies or
uh find some company that's at an
inflection point and say you know let's
trade Equity or
um I think we're pretty early in the
thinking there because we're like uh you
know we would have to it would have to
be really the right type of company that
is a high LTV B2B SAS business that's
reaching Founders and and uh you know
CEOs and Technical Founders and that
would have to be the audience like I
don't think we're gonna launch an energy
drink brand and have that make have that
kind of pencil but I don't know we're
open to the possibility
I think there's also for us I'm curious
how you guys think about it because you
are getting into this game
uh I at least I don't want to speak for
Ben
I don't want to run a company I want to
make tell stories and invest uh uh so I
don't really want to build products or
manage teams uh so I think it's likely
that we'll continue going that route I
don't know Ben has experience actually
building things so you may feel
differently but this lets us benefit
from the upside of companies using
acquired as Channel without us have to
be involved in the muck of building that
company yeah and maybe at some point
that our desire will change there but
how do you guys you guys have built
companies you guys are building products
like how you think about this I've
thought about it both ways like I I'm
like you a little bit where my I have
the most fun when I get to just tell you
know tell stories nerd out about stuff
go learn new things and then come back
with like go I want to go down rabbit
holes and then take that most
interesting you know one percent of
things that I found and shared on this
podcast or on my newsletter
um and that's that's what I like to do
that's the sort of highest enjoyment uh
but I also love money and so I'm like
okay cool and I also like the thing I
study is about how people make money in
business and create wealth and so I
can't help myself but like apply some of
the things that I learned like it's it's
very hard to resist the urge to apply
the things that you know once you know
them yeah and um but then you got to go
recruiter like basically played with
every form you could do so I I invest
both in startups as well as like cash
flowing businesses like I'll buy you
know 20 30 of a cash flowing business
that I think I can help through the
audience or uh or just through like you
know being an entrepreneur for 15 years
and like learning a bunch of stuff
um the second thing would be starting a
business so I started the milk Road off
of the podcast I think the podcast
helped us get the ball rolling there
um
and then you know I've launched the
courses or things like that that just
are ways to to take the Curiosity and
say oh I learned a bunch of stuff could
I teach it
um and then and and I also thought about
you know you know so buying businesses
investing in startups uh doing uh
building a startup on their own or not
doing any of them not being operational
at all like I've played with kind of all
of them over the past three years in
different ways like we sold the milk
Road in part because okay that business
is working and we got a great offer but
the the best part of the offer was oh I
don't have to operate any business
anymore if I do this
um that's appealing to me whereas Sam
just launched Hampton last week or I
think was that last week I saw
congratulations thank you I feel like
you don't have to do sales for the next
year based off of like you know the the
blitz that you were able to to drum up
across the Pod Twitter everywhere
everywhere that you tried to do right
like I mean you could talk a little more
about that but it seems like yeah so you
crushed your demand side
Yeah so basically in 2022 and 21 I was
inspired by Sean I was like all right
fine I'll invest a little while and so I
gave it like a six to 12 month try and I
was like I hate investing
um I totally dislike it
um I think maybe I could be pretty good
at it but I I it's not for me I don't
like taking a minority interest in
things that's
um I personally like owning all of
something and I think of myself a little
bit as an artist sometimes with these
companies like it's like my I like to be
creative and that's kind of how I like
to express myself so I prefer that with
and so that's why I launched Hampton was
because I was like this fits my interest
there I have a competitive Advantage
here and so when I announced it uh on
the Pod we now have 5 000 people who
applied and we're like and it that's
it's cost 8 500 a year to join and we're
being very meticulous and very slow
about who we're adding but that's very
likely going to be a very very large
company I think we have a CEO Jordan
who's amazing but uh like we're not
taking any outside capital and I prefer
Sean likes to do lots of things and I
know a lot of people like to do that
lots of things and I know a lot of
people who succeed really nicely with
that me personally I prefer focus and
just doing one thing at a time because I
I don't I just my brain it's really
challenging for me to jump from thing to
think of thing like an investor needs to
and so I prefer like spending five ten
years on something and so I I intend to
start company uh start a company maybe
another one in a handful of years I'm
not sure rather than investing I
actually think that Sean's way of like
doing cash flow businesses and owning a
portion of them that's actually the
easier way I think to make wealth
um I I just don't find enjoyment on it
I'm a dopamine fiend and like seeing
sales come in and like making decisions
I get like it's it's my alcohol I like
getting drunk off that how do you think
about the business of the Pod of my
first million so the podcast is owned by
HubSpot and we get paid we get paid
strictly a performance fee and so when
it kicks ass which it has we get paid
good money as if we have had advertisers
yeah
um and so but hubspot's been great like
not one time have they ever censored us
or said hey you made a bad joke don't
say that and so it's been pretty good it
is there's definitely I wouldn't say
complicated but it's a new relationship
that we're definitely trying to figure
out of like what to do because frankly
hubspot's an awesome partner but at the
same time if Sean and I bounce
they they don't have right so I
think we're both both sides of that of
that are trying to understand
what we can do and how far we can push
things and and we're definitely start
figuring that out there are you have
some and they're probably are
potentially more monetization options
for the Pod right like how does that
Revenue get split up uh like uh YouTube
ads I mean we just don't we uh turned
off YouTube ads we can't like if
somebody wants to sponsor it we don't
right so like we leave a lot of money on
the table in that regard
um but you get other benefits right so
you got to like kind of bring those out
over time and be like right so yeah like
the benefit the benefits that we have
are basically we don't do any of the
work so we record and then it goes on
the internet
um that's a pro and a con because if we
don't like how it's done then it's like
we don't like that let's fix it but
as long as it's working well it's
awesome we get paid without having to
have any expenses but then the flip side
is we have all these this
Advertiser interest and we know it works
really well let's take more deals and so
I think there's a there's a world where
we do kind of actually come to a
compromise and we have more ads but uh
that's like it's a it's a conversation
yeah yeah is there is there attention at
all with you guys wanting to use the Pod
to do stuff that generates value for
yourself that doesn't accrue back to the
MFM pod like you launching businesses
off it or is that no they're they're
they're they're they're they're great
with that and any Revenue outside of the
Pod is 100 ours events merch whatever
but let's say that they're like we're
hiring a producer now because Ben's
gonna go full time on his uh new thing
let's say let's yeah congratulations Ben
let's say that uh they're moving slow
it's like hey guys HubSpot hurry the
hell up you know you're going way too
slow I got five friends right now who
could hire and so like there's tension
there for things like that
yeah well probably all all the business
activity all the stuff you guys are
launching outside of the Pod just brings
attention back to the Pod right so like
it also brings credibility because how
many yeah people do you see on YouTube
or Tick Tock or Twitter wherever that
are like you know basically these bit
like business gurus or like you know
advice guys right if you hear the advice
guys so you like click their bio and
you're like so what have you done what
do you do oh your career is giving
advice okay but where'd you get that
firsthand knowledge do you have any
Battle Scars like Oh no you're you know
you're the bald Barber uh oh great like
you know I'm not sure that I want I'm
not sure that I want that right so so I
think that's also helpful right because
if like bald Barber by the way chef's
kiss thank you good job I'm practicing
my my improv on the Fly I decided to
take a few more risks of like oh man T
up that I'm gonna make the joke and see
if my brain in that 0.5 seconds could
come up with something and if I if I
fall flat you know two out of three
times that's okay that's still one
exactly
um so yeah basically I think it gets
credibility right like during the pod
um you know I built the milk Road and
sold it during like while the Pod was
live so that adds some credibility
during the Pod Sam launches Hampton it's
clearly gonna be successful we're
already already off to a successful
start it gives the Pod credibility and I
think that's why like why does all learn
work really well like obviously the good
banter they have good things to say but
I think a big part of it is like they
bring a certain gravity to the room
because
they're participating in the story as
it's unfair like the easiest way I
explained is all in is billionaires talk
about billionaire and my first
millionaire in my first million is
millionaires talking about millionaires
like and I've heard people like
college kids come out be like we're
broke guys talking about broke guys
that's like all right yeah like that's
that's the way to go but I think it adds
credibility because there's a lot of
people out there who will create content
tell you about the next big thing but
they don't invest they don't have skin
in the game they don't know actually
what's going on or they'll tell you you
know how to be successful and they're
you know broken depressed so it's like
you got to be careful with who you
listen to It's like I'd rather listen to
somebody who's done it before than
somebody who hasn't it's just as simple
as that yep yep what's that I think is
the whole unlock of podcasting that like
is a problem with the traditional media
industry like one of the uh it wasn't
explicitly in my our minds when we
started acquired but like I'd gone to
Business School uh I went to Stanford I
did my MBA there it was a great
experience but like the classroom
experience like the professors not the
guests who would come in who had done
stuff but like the professors who were
full-time academics and then the cases
that we would do just be like you guys
didn't do this like why are you
telling me about this like I want to
hear from the people who did it and the
journalists that cover the tech industry
it's like how many people going from
being successful Founders to entering
the journalism industry and writing for
a paper like a few like Michael Michael
morowitz by the way Michael morowitz you
know uh Doug Leone's partner Moretz yeah
sorry Morris he uh journalist turned
billionaire yeah and uh
yes yeah yeah yeah sorry
the reverse pipeline doesn't exist so
like yeah I always have to remind myself
of this when I'm reading Tech coverage
I'm like okay the the very best ones of
these people have immersed themselves in
the operator founder communities to be
able to like pick up the genesequa and
read between the lines of what certain
things mean like Dan primac is one of
these types of people but
you know a a junior journalist coming
out of Journalism School writing and
picking up this beat it's like I it's
hard to say that that's a better way to
learn what's going on than listening to
people who are industry participants
talking about what's going on I remember
once I went to a journalist uh somebody
who worked at TechCrunch I went to their
apartment in San Francisco and I just
like walked in and I looked around
and I was like this is the same
apartment as like everybody I know right
out of college has and I was like and
then they have this pen and then they
write on TechCrunch and then it looks
like very different but like this is a
person who's just a no they're a normal
person who this is kind of like their
first gig and they're covering something
that they barely like really true
honestly they barely understand that
doesn't mean they're not smart doesn't
mean they don't have good intentions but
like it's that thing where I forget the
name of it but it's like if you read an
article about a topic you actually know
about
in the newspaper you're like oh this is
oh okay I see the limitations of how
much stock I should put into this but
when you read them on topic you don't
know you're like this is the truth oh
the New York Times is an expert and it's
like there's a problem
what it's called right
do you guys remember a few years ago
when one of the I think her name was Jen
or something like that one of the
founders of Away Travel like there was
all these headlines saying like this
woman created a toxic workplace that's
horrible you gotta get I was like oh is
this a juicy story let's dig in where's
the fraud I love when you read the you
read the messages that they're
publishing listen to this yeah startup
so someone like packed like she like
opened up a package and it was horribly
done and she said if this keeps or what
did she say she goes I'm just gonna have
to pack these boxes myself because
whoever's running this must be brain
dead and I was like okay cool let's
scroll where's the good stuff yeah
they're like that's the thing she said
no we're brain dead I'm like that's the
toxic work environment like come on give
me a break that that ain't nice but
that's not New York Times headlines
give me a break like I want to see
something finally for that right
something like that she bounced because
of that like that it wasn't interested
The Other Woman not yeah I forget what
her name was uh but like I read that
article I'm like there's no fraud like
she didn't you know like there's no
alcohol involved what's going on give me
something good I want cocaine and
hookers I don't want brain dead yeah you
know what I'm saying at least like this
is why there's so much value to like
what you guys are doing that your
building businesses and talking about
them that like we're investing Ben's a
full-time VC I used to be like we know
what's going on in a way that if you're
just a journalist like you can't it's
structurally impossible well podcasts
actually have more people from the field
that come in and do it because a podcast
is easier you're talking you're not
writing there's no barrier you don't
have to like edit and like you know make
a cool fancy Tick Tock thing you know
you don't have to like layer in filters
and stuff it's just you sit down you
talk that's why you see like Reed
Hoffman we'll do a straight up audio
medium yeah just like straight audio
um or even audio with the webcam like
you know now I think that's getting a
little bit easier but basically the
podcast format I think there's a reason
why you see somebody like X athletes do
this or like you know the same thing
like you have Skip Bayless who will just
go say how this person is they don't
have the clutch Gene it's like bro
that's not a gene um you know they they
you know and he'll just like he'll make
fun of people and then you have JJ
Redick who's an ex-player old man of the
three so he's phenomenal that content
his and his point of view is so much
better than there's and that's why his
stock is going up like his views are
just going up and to the right because
he's good at this he pulls real gas when
he pulls real guests they talk like they
don't talk like they're talking to a
reporter because they played with JJ or
they played against him so they actually
open up about stuff but he's also not
trying to trap him in these gotcha
questions so there's like some mutual
trust there and then he'll just share
like you know when you're a player on
the road like you know this is the
situation fans think you're practicing
and blah blah blah but actually here's
what happens when you go and he's just
saying what's what's really going on and
so to me when you see that and again
it's because podcasting is a lot easier
if you told him hey I need you to write
like
beautiful well-written blog posts every
other day it'd be very hard to do but
for him to just oh something happened
get on the microphone give my point of
view they could do it so like you get
more credible experts in podcasting than
I think on any other like medium
this is probably actually a good use of
AI is being able to turn the ramblings
of people who are industry participants
you run that transcript through and you
say write this as if it was a New York
Times article with a strong lead and you
know this many words like it is amazing
uh how I feel like I've transformed in
my use of GPT over the last month where
I was using it to try to answer
questions which it's fine at but of
course that's the first thing you're
going to do with a prompt but my use
case recently has been take lots of
stuff and feed it in as the prompt and
then ask it to make it better so like I
wrote a LinkedIn post about our most
recent acquired episode and I fed it
I've just pasted the whole thing into
chat GPT I was like can you make this
like more exciting and can you make this
more likely to go viral and like is that
literally said so you basically copy and
pasted 500 Words you said here's a
LinkedIn post I wrote make it more
exciting let me see exactly what the
prompt was so I don't
BS on the Pod here okay no one can check
say I
can you please act as my editor and
modify this to make it more likely to go
viral as a LinkedIn post that's so funny
and it indexed way in the other
direction like it went it full of emojis
discover the secrets like a lot of like
and so I had to tone it down but I
totally used that to and I and it helped
me rephrase a lot of things where I had
like awkward phrasing that didn't flow
well it's a very good rewriter yeah
that's awesome totally agree I'm gonna
start doing that well guys uh you're
awesome man thank you thank you for
coming on
um if you're listening to our pod go
check out acquired if you're listening
on acquired
I feel like the gentleman's agreement
and the ladies understanding has become
like you know in wrestling when The Rock
would take the microphone he'd raised
the people's eyebrows you know he's
gonna hit him with like the expected but
for some reason you get excited just to
hear him say it Sam yeah I want to hear
it again that's how I feel now with your
this is your catchphrase go ahead
this is the gentleman's agreement and so
basically the way it works is look
you're going to 7-Eleven you're going to
go uh buy gas whatever you are and at
the top uh when you're about to pay you
uh see a little jar and it's for uh
muscle Justice free and there's all that
money in there and of course you don't
take that money you leave a a dollar
there No One's Gonna Stop you by the way
if you took that money but and that's
basically what this podcast is this
podcast is free us four we just
dedicated hours of our uh of our day to
do this but unlike every other podcast
this one's not free just like that jar
you got to leave a dollar meaning you
gotta go and subscribe to acquireds
podcast on Spotify as well as iTunes and
do the same with my first million on our
YouTube page and click uh you click
subscribe it's called The Gentleman's
Agreement because we're not there all
right we're just shaking our hands
ladies what is it called the Ladies
understanding the gentleman's agreement
we're not there to help you guys out
it's just honesty so everyone's doing it
don't be left out you have to do this
that's our that's our agreement we
create the content you click subscribe I
love it you guys are Innovative and
there's real value like it's not you
know for our audience if you go and
subscribe to my first million you're
gonna get smarter you're gonna get more
ideas like this benefits you so it's not
you know you're not just pulling money
out of your wallet here you're you're
doing something that's gonna
um make your life more fun and that's
the gentleman's agreement and that's the
lady's understanding David do you wanna
you wanna take us home what were you
saying
oh I was gonna ask uh I could keep
jamming with you guys for another hour I
was gonna ask you said Spotify do you
like uh where do you like people to
subscribe Spotify YouTube please well
you said earlier that Spotify is your
main thing so once we started doing the
gentleman's agreement our YouTube
channel went through the roof so
so uh we went from like 150 000
subscribers to close to 200 in like a
month or eight weeks or something we
should do a uh every pod giveaway of
YouTube premium to someone in the
comments so go go to our YouTube go to
this episode on YouTube and Just and
just type in
premium and we will pick somebody we
will pay for your YouTube premium so
that you can listen to this pod ad for
ad free in the background you can lock
your phone and walk around and uh you
can enjoy that sweet sweet 14.99 a month
that we're gonna be paying for you for
the year so one year of YouTube premium
in every episode call it it now
oh I love it that is really a reminder
to go uh comment because I am a YouTube
premium subscriber but I want you guys
to put the build yeah well thanks for
doing this guys we appreciate you and uh
we'll uh we'll have you back on and
thank you for everything
see you guys catch you guys next time
[Music]
foreign